so a lot has happened since the last
time we checked in on the activision
blizzard scandal and with the government
suing them allegations that management
enabled sexual harassment assault and
discrimination at the company and now
accusations that hr shredded documents
detailing those allegations you'd expect
a pretty significant response
well they're gonna change mccree's name
so in case you've been living under a
rock activision blizzard is being sued
by the state of california for allegedly
fostering a workplace culture that
enabled sexual harassment and abuse as
well as for discriminating against women
when it came to equal pay and promotions
this lawsuit was quickly followed by
hundreds of current and former activist
blizzard employees sharing their own
stories online about how they
experienced or witnessed sexual
harassment and misconduct at work this
was followed by activision blizzard
hiring a law firm mostly known for
busting unions to handle their internal
review people walking out on the job in
protest and then a bunch of higher ups
at activision blizzard quietly leaving
or being let go from the company but now
we get to some of the more public facing
falling out at least for activision
blizzard on august 10th the ceredo's
michael william reported that some
overwatch league casters were not using
the name mccree to describe overwatch's
cowboy themed dps character during
league matches the character has been in
overwatch since the game launched and
was named after former world of warcraft
and diablo developer jesse mccree jesse
mccree the real person not the digital
cowboy was spotted in a screenshot of a
chat log called blizzcon cosby crew
uploaded by former world of warcraft
creative lead alexa franciabe to his
personal facebook kotaku's ethan gatch
first reported on a frosty abbey's
facebook post about the cosby suite the
cosby suite was first mentioned in the
lawsuit in which the state of california
stated that it was a frosty yabbi's
hotel room at blizzcon and it was named
as such because of frasier's reputation
as someone who allegedly sexually
harassed women in the weeks after the
lawsuit came out people who hung out at
the cosby suite over the years stated
that actually the name was a joke about
bill cosby's ugly sweaters and
apparently had nothing to do with a
frosty obby's alleged reputation or the
allegations of rape made against bill
cosby however kotaku reported that
according to unnamed sources that
reputation is why afrosiyabi and other
men were photographed posing with a
picture of cosby in the hotel room this
all implicated mccree in a culture of
workplace abuse and harassment and on
august 11th gatch reported that mccree
was let go from blizzard then on august
26th the official overwatch twitter
account released a statement saying they
were going to rename the character quote
currently known as mccree to something
that better represents what overwatch
stands for
yes
you should have never done that
it was dumb in the beginning
it was stupid
yeah it was dumb
it's stupid like it's a stupid decision
to solve another stupid decision as an
aside while i do think it's only a good
thing to change this character's name
that wording implies you're gonna name
him something absurdly performative like
what name represents opposing sexual
harassment anyway apparently this name
change isn't gonna happen for a while
the character was supposed to have a
story event in september and now that's
being delayed to include the name change
the statement also says that going
forward characters aren't going to be
named after real-life employees which is
a problem that other blizzard games are
also dealing with right now until
recently mafrasiyabi had an npc in wow
named after him and mccree has several
characters in the wow named after him on
top of an entire city kotaku reported
that two other devs left blizzard
alongside mccree former diablo for
director luis barriga and former wow
developer jonathan will craft and on
august 26th the washington post nathan
grayson reported that references in wow
to borriga and with craft are also being
removed all this was happening just days
after a bombshell report from axios's
megan for manesh and steven tottillo who
reported that the state of california
was expanding its lawsuit against
activision blizzard to add temporary
workers alongside full-time employees
and that the state was alleging
activision blizzard tried to interfere
with their investigation according to
axios california's department of fair
employment and housing or the dfeh says
that activated blizzard is trying to
block employees from talking to the fbh
through ndas and by forcing them to talk
to activision blizzard before they go to
the dfeh and on top of all of that the
biggest thing in this axios report is
that the feh is alleging that activision
blizzard hr shredded documents related
to the investigation and complaints
essentially the lawsuit now alleges that
activision blizzard is destroying
evidence axios received a statement from
activation blizzard that said with
regards to claims that we have destroyed
information by shredding documents those
claims are not true we took appropriate
steps to preserve information relevant
to the dfvh investigation so yeah
activision blizzard gets a ton of bad
press for allegedly shredding documents
related to investigation about how they
may have enabled sexual harassment abuse
and discrimination at the company and
their response is to change the cowboy's
name
cool amidst all this an eagle-eyed
twitter user named the auxon 619 noticed
that activision's logo isn't in any of
the trailers for the upcoming call of
duty vanguard as kotaku's ian walker
pointed out activision's logo has been
prominently featured in cod trailers
since at least 2011. in a statement to
kotaku an activision blizzard
spokesperson stated that call of duty
has continued to expand into an
incredible universe of experiences this
was a creative choice that reflects how
vanguard represents the next major
installment in the franchise this has
become international news and as a
result activision blizzard has come to
the conclusion that the next call of
duty game will sell worse if it's
associated with well activision it's
shameless but it should show you just
how scared activision blizzard is right
now like we talked about last time they
are under serious pressure from a state
government consequences are coming if
they haven't already begun like i said
before i think changing cowboy
mcshooters in his name is a good idea
naming things after employees is
basically always going to go wrong but
if you're willing to do it you have to
be ready to change the name if that
person ends up getting milkshake ducked
i'm sure plenty of overwatch fans are
going to feel happier and even safer
knowing that someone who allegedly
participated in that toxic workplace
culture isn't memorializing their
favorite game and that's only a good
thing but that's all it is in my opinion
changing this name is a token gesture
that doesn't actually address the issues
here like activision removing their logo
from cod trailers it's a distraction
nothing else it's a distraction from a
looming lawsuit from allegations that
top brass aren't being held accountable
from employee demands not being listened
to from accusations that hr is shredding
documents presumably in an attempt to
soften the lawsuit all i'm saying is
don't let the smoke get in your eyes
nothing has changed at least
not yet
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages